hey gorgeous
hey i was just gonna make a video about
my three looks my four looks um
when it goes to the thick eyebrow look
um thank you teresa
here tier jones hill i didn't drop y'all
who knows where who the writers are my
whole story line thank you so much
thank you so much i'm here thank you
guys so much yeah it's true and
i wouldn't be happy as a and that's
stupid
so thanks for the mark visit thank you
[Music]
guys
all right lima and larry um
so we had uh amanda's final court
hearing this morning
which is a big day we were a couple
things and
amanda's future were hinging on what the
judge said today
so uh fill us in on what what happened
so originally as discussed in the last
video we were going for an
lps conservatorship and the purpose was
that
was to get amanda committed to a program
and to ensure that we had power of
attorney to make the decisions for
amanda since she was not capable
of making decisions for herself so she
was a prime candidate
these conservatorships are extremely
difficult to get
because there's a lot of evidence that
needs to be demonstrated and amanda had
all of that checked off
the issue with that was that we were not
able to have communication between the
jail
and the doctor at the jail but we had
everything else on our
end with a second doctor referring it
and so amanda has a public defender
as a public defender it doesn't
they have so many clients
that it's really hard for them to
dedicate the time required
to actually push some something like
that through
and so because of the fact
that we didn't have anything from the
other end which was the jail side
we weren't able to push the
conservatorship through so in the last
72
hours i've been trying to do damage
control and i actually woke up at 2
30 a.m this morning to make sure that
court at 8 30 in the morning went
fine and um
we diverted to
put to put in a court order for amanda
to complete one year of treatment
so she risks that if she doesn't
complete it she goes back to jail
so uh amanda today is the first time
i've seen her in
two months i think almost two months
this was a totally different amanda
yes this is i didn't even recognize her
this is the amanda
i called her amanda bear because she's
been quite responsive and
she's doing so much better just being
off the streets and in an environment
where
she's being controlled so i told her
she's doing the hard work now so
any program that we place her in then
she's going to
already have herself prepared to
participate
so she has come along quite well with
the help of
lima and mark it's just
encouraging to know that they're still
good-hearted people that will step up to
such a big
at-bat i mean this is really big
yeah lima's been amazing i mean like the
she's a thank you she's a
detailed person i used to tell my troops
to pay attention
to detail if i could have had her
picture on the example she would have
been there
i've never interacted with somebody
who's so thorough and so buttoned up
about
every single day and figuring out some
way to get around this loophole and
figure out the solution to that problem
and she just is
has been relentless exactly and amanda
this morning was
even she was unrecognizable adorable
she's put on about what 15
20 pounds probably she looks like her
and she walked into the courtroom and
said
good morning your honor and she was
respectful she didn't talk over people
she
and and the hardest part for me to watch
this was long this was she was up there
15 minutes at least 20 minutes
the d.a was reading her off all this
legalese about how
she potentially could be going to prison
for three years and the pr fines could
be this and all these things if she
doesn't do things
if she screws up with uh going to rehab
or she escapes or whatever
and she was she was she handled it
perfectly all throughout
she was so respectful and so calm
it was it was hard to watch but she did
a great job incredible
yeah absolutely i do think that it's
important to know
that um
even though all of the documents were
sent and filed
or they that all of the documents on my
end were filled out and sent
and even the program that i had i mean
i had amanda accepted into um
nobody at the courthouse actually had
the paperwork even though it was
emailed to them and so it's really
important to note that in cases where
it's a public defender there's
a lot of people these are very short
trials you know
it's it's really easy to just get lost
in all of that
so so i think that it's really important
for other people out there that are
looking to do something like this to the
for their family member
to not just purely lean on the system
and expect that just because that person
has a representative that that
representative will do what it takes
because it's not necessarily that they
don't care
it's just that they're overworked and
there's just so many people that don't
have resources
i think you've done most of the hard
work in amanda's case yeah it's been
really hard
the uh the rehab that
amanda is going to there were two
options right
so when i pitched the idea to the
courthouse of amanda going to a program
what i did was i used the documentation
from the lps conservatorship
and so one of the documents is a
one-pager
on amanda's history and what that is is
that i worked with larry
to compose it and it details all of her
mental illnesses uh that the diagnosis
her medical record
like just a very short summary jail time
that she has done
and certain issues that she's had in the
past or even traumas
and so i'm super short one pager that
that shows the severity of the issue
and um we took that one pager and we
pitched the concept of being able to
have amanda not do jail time or not just
be released
on the street where she's going to end
up reoffending and in jail
she would have been free for 10 days
right she not for 10 days
um she would have been potentially
released
the last time i came so that last that
last day that i went to court
she was set to be released back onto the
street
because there were no other options for
her and so
initially when speaking to the district
attorney
i i notified her that this was not
amanda's first time which
was already something that was known and
that that she's in a very
um bad mental state and so that was
documented on the one page document
because if you have anything more than
one page
they don't have time to look at it and
so based on that information is what
made them shift gears and say that if we
were willing to take responsibility so
basically myself
willing to ensure that i report
everything to the courthouse
and make sure that amanda doesn't
violate anything and
ensure that she follows court order
that they would consider giving her a
mandated
one-year plan which would be the
essential um
path of an lps conservatorship and she
understood it completely in court and
she agreed to it all
yeah with no one's coaxing she just said
yes this is what i want
yeah and this is something that larry's
been talking to her for a while about so
they talk daily and
i've been really surprised that she's
been actually very excited about
treatment because um
you know i have to be careful with what
i say specifically due to hipaa law
and i can't state anything that is not
already publicly known
but one of the things that we
we have been questioning is
amanda's current diagnoses from medical
professionals and the reason for that is
because
all of her the past seven facilities
that she went to
were very short stays and she was
actually diagnosed
while you know
using exactly so um it wasn't something
that
we can really go off of and so now that
she's been clean in jail for the last
two months
um we actually could have had her
transfer
today but we chose to hold her bed until
october 10th
so that she knows for a fact that this
is not a right this is a privilege
and that there are consequences that if
she messes up she will go back to jail
so
we really want her to understand that
this is an opportunity for her and she
needs to take full advantage of it
and even though she's saying that she's
excited for treatment right now and that
she really wants it
we want her to be really hungry for it
when she gets it because as you know
it's very expensive
and we've pulled a lot of strings to
make this happen
the um the options from the courthouse
when we pitch them
the concept of amanda going to mental
health care for a year instead of
jail or instead of being released and
just being homeless again
um they have a court diversion program
those diversion program can have a
hundred
up to 200 patients and
you're not getting one-on-one therapy
and you're not getting the necessary
care that you need
the program that amanda's going to be
going to has seven patients seven beds
and it's intensive therapy throughout
the day and there's a lot of different
activities
and they integrate family therapy in
there so then larry will be able to
work with amanda and and this kind of
care
uh is expensive you don't you don't you
don't
have rehab for seven patients
for you know thousand dollars a week
it's expensive
yeah so be um before i continue i would
like to state that i am not a doctor
i am not a lawyer so my advice should
not be taken in replacement for medical
or legal advice
i'm just trying to share information
with people because
this is a lot of information that has
taken
so many years to build up and
it's just a lot more simple when you
actually know what to search for
so the other factor is that
can i talk about the i know you told me
not to mention the comments
oh because no i mean there's lots of
negative comments that don't understand
what you're doing
or what you're offering or what you're
all about so if you want to clarify that
please do
exactly so i am the founder and ceo
of a tech startup and we build
technology software for healthcare
providers
mental health and the treatment centers
that we are
sending amanda to are not owned by me
and i do not get
paid by them so it's really important to
clarify that
when in the past when i've said that the
technology that i
provide facilities to is evidence-based
that means that it's already been
validated
and proven to work so we're not
using anybody as a guinea pig and we're
not testing anything
on anybody when i say that we're
providing the technology to treatment
centers for research purposes
those research purposes are to
demonstrate a value to a treatment
center
so they're already making money and
they're already getting paid
these are various i mean the the list of
rehab facilities that
the auro works with yeah is an
impressive list you've already been
working with them
they're very prestigious facilities that
like i said most people
cannot get into and i personally cannot
afford those facilities for my sisters
and my sisters
would be amanda prices times two so
my initial initiative for wanting to
help amanda or wanting to objectively
help someone that i'm not related to
that is basically to prove
so what i'm trying to prove here is not
my technology or it's not
my it's initially that we need
long-term treatment and we need
additional tools for therapists
so that they can measure how patients
are feeling and your company
provides those professional additional
tools for you that's all exactly and so
the facilities the people had you like i
think you were performing lobotomies
no not at all and the facilities that
ironically i work with
and that i supply this technology to my
um
i can't afford to send my sisters to so
the goal is to really make this scalable
and get access to it through insurance
and it'll help the world understand how
to treat these patients better
exactly and then the last factor is that
i really do want to clarify that
all of the funds go to giving.org so
i highly recommend people to
look into what giving is and who they
are
and who they represent because they've
also represented
several high profile
[Music]
charities like miley cyrus's
um charity i can't remember the name of
it but um
there's been several people should do
the research on who giving is
there's been a lot of assumptions on who
i am and the fact that i'm not a real
person because
my company was registered under another
last name
that was my old last name i did get
married recently
so i am a real person and um
a lot of speculation from people that
are not my clients it's
again it's just it's youtube's comments
a lot of people just like to
yeah create a controversy so absolutely
larry what would what's your impression
of what or what lima has done
lehman has been tremendous she's been
such a
light in my life because i was dealing
with amanda all those months
and i found out in retrospect i didn't
really know what i was doing
but i had to do something so what lima
has done is brought to me
an organized plan for amanda
and that's what i never had i never had
anybody say what are we going to do
after we do this or
conservative [ __ ] was difficult but
there was a plan and she shared it with
me and that's where we are now we're
we're in the
process of implementing it and her
presence and her attention to taking
care of
all of the things that people don't pay
attention to has made a difference
even to just been involved in amanda's
life and for how long roughly a month or
so
and it's been like there's been so much
progress it's been right
more than in the last five years right
exactly and so when she said that she's
going to help my family
not just for now but for from some time
to come
that means everything to me well just
seeing who amanda was today this morning
in court was incredible i couldn't i
didn't even recognize her yes
she looked very good very good is that
the old amanda that's
amanda bear that's her um
it's also pretty interesting that larry
is a veteran
and his insurance is covered by the va
and
amanda actually should be covered by the
va and half of the costs
that we're trying to raise on gofundme
for her right now
should actually be completely covered
under insurance
but um due to loopholes and certain
things that
larry was unaware of to file for his
daughter
it it's run its course and
for example there's
tricare which i'm still trying to figure
out because for some reason they're not
covering larry but we're unsure of why
and then the second option is champs va
and so amanda is completely dependent on
larry for everything
and before your child turns 18
which this was happening to amanda
before she was 18.
there's something that you can file
which is helpless status
helpless child status and had larry been
had larry filed it we would have no
problem
covering amanda's care so because of
that
it's been extremely challenging for him
to provide any type of support even
though he did serve his country
he's 60 percent disabled from his
service
and he's not able to he has to watch his
daughter
struggle and die in front of him without
being able to cover
her treatment costs and um
you know navigating the va is a totally
different thing but if you are a veteran
and your child has mental health issues
i highly recommend
that before they turn 18 to ask about
helpless child status
larry tell me about amanda's childhood
so tell me about amanda's mother
uh amanda's her mother her mother is a
beautician
she's very uh busy and successful at
what she does
so when i met her i was just a
workaholic so it was a lot of fun times
we
we we got along very well matter of fact
we went we met at an nbc
sitcom we were just out in burbank going
in to see a
tv show so after that we got along well
and as a result amanda was
was born but even during our courtship
i didn't get along with her because she
had a
different personality like jekyll and
hyde so i dealt with that before amanda
was born but after amanda was born i saw
how it was affecting amanda
so i decided amanda was only about 10 or
11 months i said i got to make a change
i got to do something different
and i just went and talked to someone
about going to court
so i took custody of amanda at three
years old
so since then i just raised amanda and
i did my retail business and
raised amanda until now and amanda's mom
is was
in her life she was not in her life
after we got the
legal custody and control she just
disappeared
so amanda and i just moved on with our
lives from elementary school on through
the university of northridge we
just had a good life i relived my life
through her childhood
so i must say i know amanda had a lot of
fun because i did everything that i
could possibly do when i wasn't at the
store trying to make a living
so i i told them and i said i know
people say you're spoiled i say but
we have to do things to balance our
lives i'm always working and
you know we have to do those so that's
what we did every year we went to the
the the all the places knottsbury
disneyland the county fair that was the
most
interesting thing to turn on to animals
because
city girls they know animals but to see
them and touch them and maybe ride a
shell and
that was the biggest thrill of her life
so i'm sure if she would remember
she would remember knox berry so
i just say to you amanda enjoyed her
life i spoiled as a single parent
as a retail guy she was always at the
mall she was always getting stuff
i mean that's what i did that's that's
my living
so so she had a good childhood she had a
great childhood
excellent well today was a great day
amanda's got
her birthday is sunday she's got about
10 or 15 days
before she gets taken from jail to
to rehab for one year exactly right
yes thank god miss lima thank you
i have a little bit more and you can
edit out
whatever you want to expect okay um
first and foremost is that i spend about
like five hours a day on the phone
trying to coordinate this stuff
and i don't charge for my time and this
is very personally important to me
because i do believe
that it will help my sisters in the long
run but
i've received a tremendous amount of
death threats
sorry we're gonna have to retake this
this doesn't mean there's lots of death
threats i get them too and a lot of
people
but it's not it's like like um
social media is just this cancerous
thing not even that i've had people
um look up my like try to find my
address or
and um share my address
i'm not crying on camera right now um
so it's like it's if i was by myself
if i didn't have a family i'll deal with
it
but the fact that like you know the
gofundme campaign has not been doing
it's been doing really amazing in terms
of we have 200 donors that are
super supportive but um my husband and i
actually paid for amanda's
first month of treatment um and we
secured and
we had to pay in cash um so we took out
a line of credit
and we tried to secure the at least the
first two months for amanda
um and it's it's not like we just have
money to blow around and i also have two
sick sisters that i'm responsible for
and so for people to go and and
as a startup anybody can can start a
business a small business and so
i don't get paid my team i raised a
small amount of money from our seed
round and i use that money to hire
a team of people to work with me and
those people are very talented and they
could
choose to work for a bigger company that
could pay them more but they're so
passionate about what they're doing
that they're they're choosing to be in
the trenches with me and make this
happen
and take pay cuts and work way more
hours than they should be because we're
such a small team to make all of this
happen
and my husband is taking a huge
financial risk by
helping me cover the costs and so to
know that people are trying to
find my sisters um you know or
death threats about my husband or my
sisters or god forbid like i travel a
lot i fly to la
often for what i'm doing with amanda and
coordinating care which i personally
cover
the gofundme funds go to giving and get
paid directly to hospitals so
none of those expenses larry and i
if you look at the game yeah i mean it's
just the commenters because the majority
of the
sentiment towards what you're doing is
incredibly positive yeah but there are
some people that like to
cause problems and and the death threats
that i've seen for me and for a lot of
people i interview
it's so disturbing i mean it's like i
want to just turn off the comments
permanently on my channel well my
instagram messages
i originally um told everybody
that if they want to get a copy of the
lps conservatorship
templates to message me on instagram
because i wouldn't
my clients email me so i would never get
back to people
and so my instagram messages have been
flooded with threats and
trying to find my sisters trying to find
my husband and
trying to share my address publicly and
so those things are really scary when
you're
going out of your way i'm not the best
on film
i know that there's a lot of things that
i need to work on because my job is
actually behind a computer
or in a treatment center and so these
are not things that i'm like
prepped and poised on but when it comes
to
me being on camera and putting myself
out there
and then my family getting the
repercussions or i've had to take down
my team page on my website
because some of my team members were
getting attacks and so
to know that so many people are taking
so many risks to work with me and
help build my vision and then those
people
get splattered on because of something
that i chose to do which is to publicly
you know go out there and try to be a
part of this no it's sad that social
media does this
yeah it's it's not you because it's i've
seen it many
in many cases on my channel and it's
it's sad
i think a lot of people are very
disturbed out there i will um end on a
very positive note
because i also did receive some of the
sweetest messages from people asking
um you know how is amanda and can we
send
her cards of encouragement and that's
really 99 of the
reaction to what you're doing but
there's this one percent that
causes problems and it's so it's
disturbing so um
i i've actually set up a p.o box
and we can i guess link it down below um
and i've also put on
instagram like a tip for treatment like
what to bring to treatment and what to
not bring to treatment
so if people do want to send amanda like
cards get well or
encouragement or anything um
obviously there are certain things that
you cannot
send and just so that everybody knows
everything that is sent will be read and
screened
through the facility so to be careful of
what you write
or she will not receive it but i do
think that that's really going to help
her because committing to a year
to completely change your behavior
patterns and to change your life is
um a lot and to stay on track is a lot
and so to know that
she has the support not just from me and
larry and mark
telling her that ever so many people you
know are behind you on this but to
actually
get like little get well cards from
people i think that that would be
an awesome touch because she also won't
have social media in
the treatment center yeah no it's just
sad to see somebody who's doing
something working so hard to do
something so great for somebody like
amanda
and getting that kind of negativity it's
just it's like what's matter with us
what's the matter with us like who does
that who does that
i don't even understand it but whatever
i think you're you're an amazing person
i recognized that before we even shot
our first video
thank you so much you've been more than
i even imagined
more than that and to everybody that's
been supportive
of this i am just
beyond grateful because
to be able to see like you know
all of the good that it's done and in
court today when we saw amanda
and how excited she is to know that
there's actually a change
it's not the same thing happening to her
in a real way rather than just
can i get crack now so you guys are
responsible for that
and um to everyone that's skeptical like
that's great i say question everything
if you're skeptical of me
and my intentions um i hope that you let
me prove my intentions
to you in the long run but at the same
time i don't think that there's
ever any reason to you know try to put
somebody's life at risk and even if you
think it's harmless it only takes one
person
to show up at someone's house or attack
you know a family member of my sisters
or my husband or
whatever it may be so um i just don't
want to feel responsible for putting
anyone's life in danger larry and i see
what you're doing firsthand very up
close and it's it's been
unbelievable right so positive so
amazing so consistent
consistently thorough what lima has done
for amanda thank you so much
that's amazing to me
i've never seen another person like her
no thank you well hopefully we're going
to to completely transform mental health
care together and
you know five years from now we'll all
look back and be like i can't believe
they used to only do
30 days of treatment and think that that
would be okay
so all right well today was a great day
excellent
and she gets out in 10 days yes yes and
then uh
yes and she will be transferred directly
from the treatment center
to from the courthouse to the treatment
center by the treatment center or by the
courthouse so
um there won't be any you know possible
intervene yeah but she did look great
today she looked happy and healthy and
she did
and respectfully and intelligent
very i mean there's no sign of the old
amanda know her man
told me that was amanda i wouldn't have
recognized him she was acting like my
baby
yeah today it was a beautiful day all
right all right thanks you guys good
stuff
mark you're incredible we all are myself
i'm at the roll for adjectives man this
young lady is something else
she really is thank you guys she's real
ah i don't have to go about it